yesterday at the end of the Olympics
closing ceremony they officially
announced the next city that's gonna
host and that cool yeah yeah so
congratulations to Wakanda excited with
the people who have in the audience all
white guys are doing this at the
Pyeongchang Olympics a number of speed
records were broken did you know that
true story yeah by far the fastest was
Mike Pence running away from male figure
skaters
terrible mining and I apologize a lot of
companies now distancing themselves from
the NRA you've heard about that right
yeah yeah yeah over the weekend a lot of
major companies announced they will be
cutting ties with the NRA including
Delta Hertz and MetLife here's the one
that really shocked me today the NRA got
dropped by Isis Isis was like those guys
are crazy because that discount at the
annual meeting of conservatives called
CPAC a woman who criticized Donald Trump
was booed and escorted out by security
yeah this is the third time this has
happened - Melania so that's not a sari
I see what he did yeah not probably not
the woman but that's okay I got fashion
news okay yeah
when me have hashing news right right
Andy and I are wearing suits by Sears
anyway
hey why did Billy cut to your suit as if
to confirm yep it's from Sears right
it's from their Husky boys collection in
a fashion show that took place yesterday
I believe Dolce & Gabana sent their
handbags down the runway on drones
instead of models yeah but first each
drone was forced to lose 10 pounds must
look thin
drones don't talk that's so stupid
you